[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right what is up everybody names are
backwards but I'm Persia this is Richie
good morning um good morning today it
just released battlefront 2 Star Wars
Battlefront sees rise the Skywalker
events it started it started it's here
um things are a bit staggered in terms
of release like the games that were are
the modes and stuff that's coming to the
game and the maps and the new world and
stuff like that but
yeah wait hold on let me make sure
everything is good for sure yeah I think
we're good all right whoo-hoo good boy
yeah there are some things staggered
around I heard there was gonna be like
some new maps and stuff like that but a
few things aren't actually dropping
until the 20th there's also more content
coming through like next month in
January so it's there's a ton of stuff
going on they're also having like a
celebration edition of this game wool
which comes with all the content that's
been released for the game in the last
two years plus the new content on the
way so today we are gonna play some
co-op because if I am correct all these
are new please bear with me you guys to
be fair I haven't played battlefront so
this first one have not played much of
two but yeah you know Star Wars
it's all the rage right now I played
fallen order which was fun oh yeah you
know Star Wars hype never goes away in
general it's just been coming back over
and over I've also been trying to read
the information on the EA website right
now and it looks like this is a private
of this update it's or maybe it's just a
menu update that might be be a thing as
well because it does say with this
update we'll be updating some of our
menus to give you more control over
which faction you want to play us to
begin with this will focus around co-op
heading into co-op menu you'll now have
the ability to select from play any much
down here incarnate and then all of
these galactic Republic resistance
first-order separatist alliance and then
it says we'll be updating more game
modes with a similar menu structure oh
ok so they just changed the structure of
this menu it's gonna scroll up see what
else in here
so it says it also mentions in update
notes that there's a new co-op trilogy
starting with jakku took oh man these
names are guys but yeah there's a time
of new updates heroes hero appearances
there will be three new appearances one
each for Finn Rey and kylo Ren in this
update yeah there's a lot of stuff
actually so if you want to read up on
everything just head on over to the EA
website it's a full page new planet they
keep calling a new plan because they
don't want to spoil things this is
obviously being released in tandem with
the movie so yeah and then we also have
a couple of new classes what's going on
check but yeah sorry chat I'm just
trying to get you a lope give you the
lowdown on everything that's going on so
far I'm actually a little bug lip the
maps aren't coming out bring up a few
days because that's what I wanted to
check out I want to check out the new
the new planets and stuff so yeah the
new maps will be in the heroes and
villains mode and the coop moons no pass
is lana del rey in the deal i want to
see the Rey is I am a fan of wanna
dorium yeah bring her and let her do the
soundtrack so I guess let's try out some
let's go up and see if we can try these
new class
[Music]
wait I like I selected a single one and
it still put play all all I know is in
the trailer I saw Ray in the rise of
Skywalker trailer for this update I
didn't see her
[Music]
what up crime okay Lucy yeah hopefully
this doesn't take too long to search it
didn't take too long to find a matching
heroes and villains earlier so if
anything it's good switch over to that
I'm also god-awful in this game please
bear with the gunner is the best are you
talking about the new gunner grim oh
snap our air getting into a match yeah
right the speed drive so we could record
it's okay
can I still ice womp womp it was because
I tried to jump in early and play a
couple of matches of this so I couldn't
lose familiarize myself cuz when I
played the first battlefront
I think I was playing that on console I
think good times it was such a long time
ago oh man we ain't got no money
we broke we broke hey echo how's it
going
thank you for joining us
we don't even got no coins
oh okay biota
oh are you still waiting for him player
okay I was like what is happening one
needed one needed yeah roll through here
real quick thing I went too far - hello
hello everyone in the chat echo says
house lights lights is good not too bad
for a Tuesday huh money fasten unlock
everything pretty quickly noted let's
see if we can get some money and unlock
some of the goodies yeah
all right yeah it's a new planet coming
out on the 20th the six troopers the red
ones
I see whoa all of these things wrong Oh
busy and go from Raisa the Skywalker
yeah can I upgrade my cards
the ones I have currently I have six
when I have points we're good
oh is it because I have no oh I have not
leveled up and I know we're all right so
let's see I can unlock some of these
health line elimination
oh that sounds useful yes yes we're
still waiting for one more person yeah
there were a lot of little updates here
yeah there was a ton of update notes
just like quality-of-life fixes hero
changes which is pretty cool I mean if
you guys have really been following
along with this game you'll notice over
the last few years that from where they
started to where they are now
it's um almost like a completely
different game a lot of quality of life
updates in general
Darth Binks oh my gosh who do you think
the new the two new heroes will be
mm-hmm good question I mean I'm kind of
on the baby Yoda wave myself I could get
you know so much more baby Yoda in my
life
what always all right we're still
waiting for one more player I don't know
if I should back out
research let's do that
sure for sure or if anything real like
we can hop into heroes and villains
what's this one what a great going
welcome back good to see you again
BC says would you say this is worth
picking up if you don't have it I would
definitely get the and your Star Wars
fan I was definitely get the celebration
edition just because it comes with
everything and you don't have to worry
about like buying everything separately
yeah it's like the full version right
complete version
you know from what I've heard from
people who played this from start till
now the games come a long way it's
improved a lot a lot of new content is
also on the way I kind of feel like this
game is slid under the radar because of
where it started compared to where it is
now so give it a shot you guys don't be
afraid
[Music]
all right wait finally I got oh wait now
the cards my cards
I know I need to go yeah okay
crime says you can get this game for
$5.00 it's an EA access play with
friends going to need to monitor when
servers get full interesting good
looking out crime there we go
they ready to strike at one of the core
separatist planets get ready so this
attack will continue when we've taken a
droid what's up Marco
[Music]
over here on the follow them
[Music]
but I want to shoot someone with throw
it like a shoddy kill
[Music]
yeah they're doing the dodge rolls
[Music]
well I don't always like okay he was
like Alden it looked like all right
there you go
got him no I live for a while they're
good with all their dodge rolling
jumping around you were halfway through
grab Brendan says check your other
troopers and hero cards they can help ah
Thank You Raven back in it yes sorry
guys
bear with me
and they make you run all the way back
so far always been a third person game
with our car correctly yeah
Elite sometimes I played it it can't be
both I think right here it's
normally third I remember in third but
like I did earlier
[Music]
the Pentagon
oh no he's comfortable and
oh do you like 360noscope little droid
yeah they're good okay Marko's like
Marco wants the physical version of the
celebration of their simply a physical
case something yet oh yeah I want battle
points at increase three for sure there
we go
yeah little by little sorry we're out
they almost got a
I thought I was a bad guy I see somebody
up up on the d-pad roller I might be
better huh if you're down right yeah we
got the Xbox one controller
I know that's how I'm more comfortable
hey go
yeah that horoscope says it was a good
game but I had a rocky start I remember
that it's no joke brothers we have fast
running out of time then we need to
finish this attack here we go for some
reason I thought you Ivana I know you're
still fighting droids on the planet okay
now Oh
I didn't see that option come up I
probably dismissed it no biggie
oh my god a let's go that guy was my
network yeah oh let it down okay let's
see if we got some points now
[Music]
man this old machine gunner thing looks
crazy I know I I want to be used that
you just like flip us off your character
take part and I can't do it
oh I just took me straight there
now we'll do some heroes and films for
sure oh here we go
there's so many so many choices oh this
is two-on-two
naah four-on-four
Hayato it is in the chat no oh it we
should be on the podcast the after dark
that puck is so cool oh yeah
[Music]
but yeah yeah that before what else I
mean look at the details of this event
sure oh wait go up a little bit final
jets a cool Oh Joshua okay okay okay
okay
we I was actually on the right track
here now that we had finally gotten some
point so I'm gonna go back to co-op so
we can use the jet trooper oh yeah wait
let me see if I can plug in yeah let's
get that Xbox one controller for game
[Music]
that cable should work right theory the
that's the mouse there we go
oh whoops sure you can have access oh no
we got disconnected wait what the heck
why we were just thought was it because
I plugged in this this thing [ __ ] but I
didn't read all of it stand by folks I'm
just wanting to test something okay I
like unplug the USB oh that's a good
question Briggs jet trooper versus Jango
Fett who wins it both got the same
little pack oh boy
what is happening okay there we go sweet
like Oh No okay controller action
activate sweet
there we go let's see
hey Randall so all right max go ah there
we go jaja says I would just jump on at
the same time it's a method
[Music]
all right now that we are on controller
and not keyboard let's see yeah this
should run a little smoother huh I know
what we are playing on PC right now we
just uh we just plugged in the Xbox one
controller though credits you know
[Music]
[Music]
fall back what from where John did I
joined live why I think you were thrown
into this game
well hey Tommy my storm troopers hired
my dude
Chad is saying if you want a
first-person it appears to be up on the
dependi bed
thanks thanks
real smooth
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
I try it every direct Colombia pad just
in case
now they're like hold up on behead if
you want that's army don't forget it
you're just trying to get me killed
[Applause]
there we go
[Music]
let's speed this from where
Oh gene everywhere my butt was hiding in
the dog
oh they sit down on the bed not up on be
bad
that's if one even like you personally
like first person
I don't think it really matters for
yeah Vanya paramedical
get in the boat I mean the ship yeah
you're betting be right now we got this
Ben he is artist
I believe
go
ah there you go
thanks next time I wanna have enough
points to use the jet trooper right wait
did we get these is be secure
or as though you're just defending our
analogy the
although I don't know if any
oh there he goes you got him
oh boy
oh no down for a while I was about to
take my shotgun out okay okay I can use
judge shoot right now wait
sweet there's some cool okay you're at a
buddy's where it's hot okay
first person this is aisle
Oh
[Music]
that's fun I see loads up on the bottom
there bottom right to jump right into it
that's fun I can see how can be really
helpful
[Music]
I'm like I'm out of here
coeruleus is one of my favorite games
dice
even after two years it still plays like
a charm
yeah oh dang curious oh I gotta be like
that
oh okay special characters don't go
first night to pee every time I was born
with him I ran out of money worth it
dang Oh your your settings are control
settings
we've having to hold it down kind of
preferred the Tago from the Thames for
certain games
[Music]
[Music]
here they come
[Music]
that's pretty sick
[Music]
now I'm out got this
let me try another dripper
I wonder if this little blank spot is
where our actual special trooper is
supposed to be yeah let me try some dual
wheel - action oh my squad is destroyed
just under three minutes and hold it
down
so I'm still like a little confused wait
what is happening here a little confused
as here
the exact dates and times that a lot of
this stuff is being released I really
wanted to check out the new world drop
into this game but after I looked at it
they said that wasn't coming for another
three days
Wow yeah oh so I'm actually going to say
yeah there you do know with junior
yep the play is a first order to play
the new classes
[Music]
we'll hop into the first order after
this I need to figure out what I'm
holding it down to eight you got this oh
there it is
oh hey maybe I shouldn't be trying to
read board
[Music]
and it'll wait oh oh yeah instantly
surrounded
oh maybe spotting on him see why yeah
they give you that option to spawn so
far away yeah I think we're already
pretty far back into these
yeah we're just going to camp it out
boom that true grim reaper says the new
map was playable for the first hour by
mistake
[Music]
because they're almost out of
reinforcements okay definitely
we're stuck all right so the goal after
the so it's a first order we're gonna
watch the menu was a little more clear
about what
especially for people who maybe are
jumping into you the sound effects are
great Chacho mentioning like young
teammates the spawn they were just too
far up and when I tried to spawn on one
of my teammates earlier I definitely got
body yeah we tried alright we are let's
go back first order but now I feel like
I've got a grasp on what I'm going here
so we're good good stuff I can't tell
whether I like it better in first person
service
all right this one wait no why does it
search all of them when I'm I'm trying
to just select it just went played this
one only it searches all for every sock
or whatever see what we can get into
here maybe it just looks like it's
searching for all of them
as long as you get to check out the new
reinforcements it's like right oh yeah
here we go here we go
yeah except what's in the bottom middle
of this one is there just nothing there
so we need a thousand points no day off
with an assault guy
first order and resistance okay
no not clear is in the titles but clear
as in which items are a part of this new
Skywalker event specifically I mean
obviously it's pretty clear on what play
was Cyr playing but yeah like which
Blake it didn't really say clearly in
the minute that Oh first order in
resistance like this try walking coastal
shells but a little tougher the one in
price you didn't have access to many of
if I did you know
[Music]
got it
what's that other again
[Music]
Raymond says the syph troopers are the
best troopers and ones a jet troopers
get your boy was pretty fun huh
and then Grimm says not at our Gunners
top
[Music]
oh boy defeat
I like this one
got that cool down
oh okay
there you did it
that's me I'm gonna battle
these are new boys
mowing them down surgeon oh joy I'm also
camping behind this little wall here
it's better than being completely
surrounded like that last night yeah
we're looking from everywhere
[Music]
oh right you got your squad here I
thought I looked over there okay but I
can choose someone else now ooh all
right but uh yeah let's start with this
guy
we'll start Suites die well area every
area is too hot right now available do a
feat in are you fine
there we are alright so let's see it oh
I guess I should have read his abilities
cool Reds game all check it out
yeah you like my red hot
who is that good though you're gonna
stick out like a sore thumb bring it on
[Music]
did that like oh you have a combat rush
ability that will boost the sprint speed
will get lost in the sauce you also have
an you have an oppression grenade this
blow up right away on contact I missed
it
and you have like asked a nobility
secret package
stewpot right now
[Music]
Oh Brandon after you guys went to the
Star Wars landing neither I'm gonna try
to go to my birthday
does he
holding it down Fraser yeah I like
well there it is No
there you go your gun was it cooling
down
I gotta get bill a bar
oh yeah
oh where
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
well we've gotta move
[Music]
I like his weapon yeah that one here
nice boy
can't see the blood you're ready yeah
they can't tell how my friend injured
I see you see the cooldown pattern for
your gun yeah chat says it hit the blue
it goes down faster but
they're good it runs all the way out
yeah is that like your dear political
there you go Wow oh it was one of those
grenades
he always had on great music resumes
canhardly by him in an epic battle
absolutely
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
the resistor
[Music]
oh my god yep yes ten seconds though if
you wanted us to do that you got this
kind of died down on this I'd never mind
this what I said that on activating it
in five seconds oh cool
gold for superpowers blue for faster
[Music]
well that was a fluke we can try out I
really want to try the gunner now that
you got more Floyd playing sound let's
see what's available now frozen what
happened oh well
okay sweet
I guess that was fun that's it to her
hole is the best one so far really like
the gun they have
Jane Doe gg gg it's pretty fun oh my go
away look it looks crazy
[Music]
alright yeah look there she is
okay now we got a you are time first
yeah get these points [ __ ] let's go
Oh
oh yeah toss for you right away
no you jumped into a lake match I wasn't
your fault
hey good body by kylo Ren that's how
we're feeling instantly
[Music]
if I stay in here
okay sweet yeah yeah little XP anyone
said you got like 600 teeny match there
I know underwhelming but alright
actually those pretty action-packed you
got like sliced and then it ended Kyllo
in stolen I know right right well like
that who else is there let's see oh yeah
so 4,000 points why no they expensive
yeah I think KFX is also new scroll down
I think I saw something else yeah yep
what the first order wants with jakku is
anyone's guess but will not make it easy
for them ready that fences
you guys it let's get that Modi get
these points see everyone else is also
like a regular grunts and really trying
to get the points to everything the
first order throws
[Music]
have you been digging first person since
you switched over you wouldn't going
back and forth actually yeah that's
right it's not for everyone
[Music]
oh I passed
there you go Thunder tank
I'm like I'm a good guy this time
[Music]
see his hi oh man
[Music]
one of them over there there you go
god
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
well it happened our new defenses have
been marked move into position and let's
beat back the first order attack I
gently went the longest possible way
America no oh I remember this area is
this for the last time
[Music]
like all right it's okay because now I
am oh no oh no that's a bad I missed it
I uh
I think if you already own the game this
update or this upgrade or whatever is
cheaper than the celebration Edition
Bundle
always have lined up
oh I forgot that's all right your focus
yeah you have to focus like everywhere
else Oh flametrooper
yep you're barbecued he's still so happy
it's all right like what's right oh man
what happened last time I got him
fall back and concentrate our defenses
in the next sector Jane
I feel like I'm gonna kill him anyway
charge smooth
oh my feelings Lda all right guys we got
to defend this these are good positions
we should be able to beat the first
order attack from here is that so
[Music]
[Music]
I'm like trying to get wound up a little
bit for sure keep it spinning there you
go
from the top up here is much more
helpful crap
Oh
see you Raymond thanks for joining see
you next time
nope goes over this they seem to be fine
he is like blinking probably why it's
hot
[Music]
now you can run full-speed which is
gonna do
not Oh like the optimal way we've
actually retreated we're ahead of
everyone else I'm actually still a 100%
loss there we go a voice actor oh that's
cool the voice actor sounded familiar
oh wow does it Bucci your back must be
stopped here okay
is all we have people running for my
life
who
[Music]
got'em
that's fine
all right I've had enough let's see what
hey thanks
all about
oh man you got homes down boy eight
minutes
got them Oh
oh no no you just came through
thanks ball myself up did you check the
name right there your feet I thought it
the little icon oh wait I should read I
want to read her the abilities yeah he's
like Timmy thought it was like a launch
pad scanner beacon okay well I should've
killed you this
well I just got hit by something yeah
rapidfire brunt forest melee strike
second b-team okay she's like
there you go we sleep up here cool
there you go see everyone else we were
[Music]
[Laughter]
feeling like soup trooper is my favorite
so far it's been the funnest one for
sure the jet troopers very tried
I got tried the first-order jet Schubert
[Music]
okay I think so far as its trooper has
been my favorite yeah same here
I don't want to go back to the other one
oh yeah yeah because we also didn't
carry the first order
[Music]
yeah so I think even though it says
they're all searching it is only
searching okay listen I picked okay yeah
well Brandon asked what games will you
be playing over Christmas break I am
going to play the spider-man DLC because
that's something I haven't gotten to do
yet either yeah yeah you know realize so
much later that they did happy LC for it
so go back to that I finally wrapped up
Kingdom Hearts 3 yeah that's another
thing we I'm gonna like go back to cuz
the DLC bounced yes I am excited but
that's a wild over birth finally
finished three and because the DLC looks
good I want to play kinda green we'll
see how it goes
my final like opinion on Kingdom Hearts
3 is that's gameplay and graphics are
absolutely amazing I just did not enjoy
the story that look called me I wasn't
in love with the story
any attack but I also didn't give it any
given much much of a chance how to play
that much of it oh yeah it was a little
easier I would say then I felt like 1 &
2
also please welcome finally nice men
that roxas fight fine
the point-to-point I final mix Indra
Brennan says I'll be finishing plague
tale all right
what are you get into that too maybe I
can find a sale I should have checked it
out on the side
I on cyber money as when I bought the
spider-man DLC bundle oh there was a
bundle
yeah it was like 20 bucks goes cremate
and I love that game last year yeah
there's one is
when I first came on I was playing at
like
so I actually didn't even omit but I did
please
yeah
[Music]
there's one out I know it's like
No
going for night
oh yeah I won't totally diss every time
this is a good long-range weapon her
medium-rare touch-up says I'm gonna go
play which was three again he gives the
play for the switch when you think re
playing on ps4 Xbox what you got
[Music]
you
got him
[Music]
oh sure I thought was energy perfect hey
I'll play me but now I have enough
points it happens here we go the actual
jet super that I wanted to try out
oh yeah we are flying now hope you don't
take fall damage
that was dope though Ivan says play
percent of 5 ooh ChaCha says I'm gonna
play Witcher on the PC gonna max out
those graphics tell you
those rabble rousers must be getting
desperate
setting up defenses he's like what
you're alive
Oh I was matching so hard that I totally
ruined okay okay yeah
guys it shook when stormtroopers can aim
a little bit ha ha that's not candy at
all cut the stress that was only a
little bit
Oh
he just blew it aside from nowhere
[Music]
yeah let's guard him
oh I like straight-up jumped into their
way I have some
back in it here we go this is crazy
Oh chuckle okay that's one
they were everywhere oh I see I don't
think I can use them because someone
else is using them I got a rush it down
super bad yeah resistance have Reedus
person their defenses
come on post-marketing excited
[Music]
of course of course there are no enemies
to fight there they are
[Music]
[Applause]
okay here's where the party's at
gonna work I'm such a dramatic balls
like oh we got I see every time you die
I don't know maybe I just didn't pick a
lot of times where that wasn't ready to
race
it can only be one
gotta like
Oh
yeah hey greetings from Brazil love that
deflecting
oh nice
[Music]
I'm slipping
[Music]
hoo-wee Christopher suggests jumping a
lot with him oh yeah
[Music]
what
heroic sacrifice it's very fun fun you
want to jump back in the silver well he
did pick him the same sad life
all right we're back to sets you really
okay
I think yeah I think you're the best
MoDOT in general but I like his weapon
why that fire rate Oh No
[Music]
rip super rip well I'll light some
people on fire there you go go variety
here
that guy got my love
whoops
oh this is so hot right now
[Music]
we love into PT and morning it get it
clean
Brendan says Sakura was really fun yep
get our announcement our game of the
year
oh no what is that guy with the ninth
about the hair
dang
[Music]
maybe that's everyone Oh
[Music]
Oh
Oh victory must be secured now 20
seconds bruiser slow it down it thing oh
[Music]
never mind
pick it up again
hi
oh cool yeah - that's how I thought it
would be useful just ducking out of a
fight
Bosco Powell says - Portugal in greeting
from Malaysia
over time Oh Roger you gotta get back in
there
[Music]
brand
greetings from LA what a
[Music]
good to have your brand-new
no quietly I ain't so good outing oh you
hey Andrew thanks for joining us
[Music]
yeah yeah oh yeah do not let that one
you're close health bar
whoa
Oh
[Music]
oh no they've all gotten so useful
[Music]
man overtime is still going
[Music]
while we have used motor oil because
over joining from Sweden wow that guy
hiding out back there's a jerk I do like
how lazy we may not be field either like
it was him let me just fly there see
y'all there now we were just jumping the
gun
competing from all around ya have you
ever thought like remix
oh I should have tackled them
whoa at least he is pretty good at like
you know flanking you and not letting
you camp out in one spot me I guess you
don't want to be wanted to be too easy
but he's they surround you like no other
[Music]
what uh
oh you okay you gently fall down your
whoa up Brandon's out he's keeping up
he's asking what you beginning a switch
for Christmas Persia I know like the
ingredients okay you ready
[Music]
unless we secure this sector right away
who will face defeat into it
heyyo
[Music]
[Applause]
okay happy
we're overtime
oh boy
yeah
nope
[Music]
right now we're just checking out the
new reinforcements seven added
but the
math and planets and stuff
which is actually something I just
learned
but some of its here at school
mmm
got him
[Music]
no Friendly Fires
so close caps almost done
yeah security we're seeing to cleanse it
all seditious evidence
so yeah Kalos when the jet trooper the
new jet troopers pretty fun it's all
over the place I like that
sit super missus troopers floor like
this no doubt stylish red right there
51,000 Jesus roof hey you got 37 carry
Eunice the Horror Show says it can be
overwhelming for a new player yeah a bit
a little bit but once you get the hang
of it it's pretty fun that's pretty fun
like I said earlier I've really only
played battlefront one so this is kind
of my first dive into to my was pretty
it's pretty fun so far I'm let's say
you're doing great
thank you try it
too much Star Wars the past couple years
says Brandon that's a hot tank man I
mean it is so like for die-hard Star
Wars people they're like this is
degraded they're living it yeah yep I
yeah that's definitely yeah it's it can
be polarizing for sure there's a lot to
keep up with I don't even know who's
fighting who I know half the time I'm
swinging at my own TV right you're in my
gunner Church I've been looking over
there health bars like okay that's a bad
cat those were warning shots the key
remember your storm simulator
is that what that enemy lobbying
[Music]
[Music]
hmm sad dog roll
oh I'm at night hey you got it we just
weirdest noscoping that hip-fire though
I just wanted enough to switch already a
Halloween
[Music]
whoa there you go
didn't see you come
I always feel like someone's shooting
behind me and then I could never find
[Music]
hey I wasted all my gold ammo
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
yeah
you loved that doll just in time
thank you all right I know he has a
really cool like ability here I got some
how to use it
Oh
I like it a lot guys
right I'm addicted their style same
Oh
Ziya turret
Oh
[Music]
why do you have to do this rip
[Music]
yeah I think
although you play really well with the
Oh
[Music]
Oh No oh I keep mixing up my left and
right bumper abilities I was like trying
to do a little dash of a freaking
throwing the grenade at myself like a
total pro oh that's me
Oh surrounded I want you to fly away
like that other it was hot oh yeah I
wanted to read him okay so my ellaby an
RV scan the area to real reveal amounted
anything
oh okay it just can't it just skansen I
thought it was like a auto lock you know
like oh if I tagged them or something
the resistance forces had regrouped but
it will not avail them secure those
command posts you miss being that guy
Oh
Oh deflected right now oh man all right
my homie nice Dodge
I hear you bang it super high mm-hmm so
I'm feeling below it out
josée Oh
[Music]
Levens wait are they going for B I think
so yeah that's too quietly or maybe they
are I don't know maybe the traffic's
that be some people are coming back
Oh
even says can't wait to go home to play
this clear days oh man oh I see it stops
them from memory generating I just see
the bus line
good stuff nice SAP
[Music]
you like to have
we will lose this battle soon unless you
step off the attack
[Music]
nice hey Boyd thanks for joining
GUP you back in the chat hey welcome
back
always a pleasure
we shall soon destroy what remains of
the magnetic resistance of this planet
prepare to advance
now guess someone got their sink on me
the resistance forces are facing
imminent defeat I own fight all the
harder but so shall we take that
position
Ben Williams in the chat says this man
is so underrated did you play from the
start Ben have you been a fan from the
beginning just wondering cuz that's such
a rocky start but you know I want to
know you
Oh
very good we're good we're good
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
got this Roy oh nice Todd
alone
all right let's go
I'm not gonna lie I'm having a lot of
fun what is it you're into it great good
Gabrielle touchdown there are any
purchase troopers in this game this is a
farm order traigo chuckles I see but I
double-check there's a lot of new
playable characters but no birds
troopers
Oh
40 seconds burger oh wow oh that was the
movie she was tired of my [ __ ] you're
done
[Music]
alright she's dead
Oh
[Music]
all right
now our team is their people and then
we're playing against yeah we are
playing against las Tres this would not
be is going as well and we're playing as
drawers
shoot this on the back thank you
Oh
Wow shadow says I'm getting fallen order
for Christmas
have fun if it's a little Souls II
little souls are you play the whole
thing a good day
[Applause]
yeah I guess we could do some of the
heroes versus villains if we want some
PvP action but I was playing that
earlier and I was getting slicing let's
end on a good note I don't know if it's
up to you Oh
party 1237 that's how into this game I
know no we're an OTB I know I'm like
[ __ ] I wish hadn't started enough
there's gonna turn off the streaming
keep playing
I was unknown says thus it troopers look
dope they were they were like I think it
was purchased favorite are a stream
we're already over time but I'm just
gonna play one more and then let's do it
yeah
unless you're not you're busy me no
client okay this is a if we can do one
more that's fine yeah it's pretty fun
you know scan has detected an incoming
resistance so yeah I'm really excited
now it's the defense's for Windows the
new planet in the new Lance your honor
three more days
it's done we thought it was today show
these resistance insurgents what we made
for your hand yet
now you reloading
so much died roll
yes no you get them
nice very laid-back no there no ah there
we go
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a nice way to look at it like you
gotta win something to lose or you got
to lose some of the wind sound so let's
try this again in a different area Oh
Brandon asked me Friday this week the
double check all right last one of the
year we'll see you we'll see who's
around
Oh
oh that's a cool ability now for you but
all right there we go yeah now you're
back to the fifth trooper
oh you're not far from the exit oh there
you go he'll like kiss
[Music]
it's taking boy
oh my god the way
god
[Music]
shadows was bringing up Mandalorian
that'd be cool if they had a an outfit
or a character on here next year yeah
this would be like okay like uses one
big ability and then he does go to sleep
first everyone goes oh looks at them and
then that's me distracted me kill
everyone
[Music]
that Horror Show he's been watching he's
like I have 20 more minutes before you
close the shop can't wait to go home oh
my god that's great man we good glad
we're getting pumped for this again
don't let go you got this oh yeah
perfect
Oh what we're like a thousand people
over this excellent dodge roll Oh
yeah shadows baby Yoda is one power
distract tell you you just Matt you're
pulled in like oh no like you you'll aim
at him but you won't be able to shoot
here triggers like oh you be the best
with this soldier though you're doing
great he's pretty dope
no he died right away now chat is
listing all his tweezer and baby oil
futures two to come lifting things with
extreme effort napping for a couple of
days eating everything in sight oh yeah
he would be Oh pig
what is it
[Music]
oh look 100 points for sacrifice and
folio 200 points for every time I
sacrifice
[Laughter]
man
from down
ooh I like that idea Kanye says baby
Yoda s coordination oh yeah that would
make the most sense
you ingrate no are you too far yeah all
right up there we go
hey would they do that makes me feel
like I'm dying
all right well soldiers of the first
order these positions I think you're on
I like this setting
feels a little more controlled when it's
indoors like this
yeah outdoors URI getting shot from
every angle no fun will fun but Hector
[Music]
that's an indestructible railing though
[Music]
oh there you go
[Music]
Brandon thanks for sticking around have
a good one see you tomorrow if you're
back
oh you okay so if the enemy caps it even
just one point you have to fall back
around
[Music]
I'm this good as a birther
oh yeah co-op even you up a hole down a
Oh
[Music]
guys
hey why don't you realize I'm reloading
oh yeah
there's so much going on over there
nice oh my god okay
palpable
ouch
they were everywhere where do it hold
down a we've got this
oh man
what anyone's taking weeks oh wow
whack it's like there's a ton of people
and then
Eric their industry today even if it's
not like every child is spot on is like
if Tim bucks have one good shot on you I
think is that one eyes on the corner
oh my gosh it's mayhem right now three
minutes
[Music]
signing in the pen
we're all just jumping and rolling
around it works
[Music]
Oh No
I hate that that corner that left side
[Music]
hi
[Music]
those are the homies
Oh No
[Music]
one more minute
[Music]
push your homie out the way out
Oh Dave
stand your ground that's right the
heroes and more vast amount on the 20th
after the movie license
[Music]
today though we got v trooper who
appointed now the OBC and gunner the jet
troopers the perfect spy
[Music]
Oh any cost children doesn't get this
[Music]
300 T okay
okay you got it all right the bullet
Alateen want bein back off
[Music]
oh it's raining oh my god she was asking
me can't even get out of there great
stand out was the red soldier guy via
the synth troopers why am I so evil what
alright man that was fun
GG is everyone and thank you all for
tuning in with us today
yes we had a blast more content on the
way for battlefront
to the Skywalker events oh yeah new
characters for super fans v Cooper is
definitely the homie I'm gonna turn down
the sound on thank you guys so much for
tuning in uh tune in with us every
weekday at eleven except for this
upcoming week because Christmas break
yeah yeah so thank you guys so much
shooting in we will see you later bye
you